DAN GALVIN: Hi.
I'm Dan Galvin, an Engineer and
Developer Advocate at Google.
And this is a Google data
center, 110,000 square feet
of efficiency in
Council Bluffs, Iowa.
This is the beginning
of Google scale.
And when I say Google scale,
I mean the architecture
that powers 1 and 1/2 million
Android activations per day,
6 billion hours of
monthly YouTube viewing,
and 20 billion pages crawled
and indexed for Google search.
To do this, we built a
network that spans the globe.
And this is what it looks like.
Our data centers
are places where
science becomes art, such as
in this data center in Oregon,
where the labeling of a
function of a cooling pipe
makes a facility feel like
a multicolored playground.
These servers in Georgia
are lit by efficient LEDs.
Green and blue mean
that all is well.
If there was a
problem, a technician
would be immediately able to
locate it when dispatched.
While you and I might never
get this close to the inside
of a Google data center,
such as this one in Oklahoma,
our code can.
Residing on the same
compute, storage, and network
that allows Google scale, using
the Google Cloud Platform.
Applications run on the
Google Cloud Platform
using Compute Engine, our raw
infrastructure as a service.
It is the fundamental
building block
for services such as
Google App Engine,
our platform as a service.
This allows you to
build your own software
as a service at the top
of the pyramid stack.
Here's an overview of what
makes App Engine scale.
First, we start with disk.
These disks are distributed and
mirrored across data centers,
with different
access layers based
on the needs of
your application.
Cloud Storage is
great for large files.
Datastore is deeply distributed
and works with very large data
sets.
While Cloud SQL has the
versatility to handle complex
SQL queries.
In front of that, we have
lightweight and distributed
app servers.
We provide memcache to allow
you to reduce data storage
operations and improve
performance as you scale up.
The front end provides load
balancing and session delivery,
freeing up app
servers more quickly.
The services then
connect to the internet
through yet another series
of distributed systems that
provide features
such as edge caching.
Well, how does this
work in production?
For Song Pop, one engineer was
enough to identify the scaling
road blocks and
quickly solve them,
taking a product
from 0 to 2.4 million
daily active users in
a year while working
on adding features to the
game at the same time.
Cloud Storage also helped as a
scalable, affordable, reliable,
and high-performance
content delivery service.
Many of you may
recognize this icon.
What many of you may not
know is that Snapchat
is hosted on App Engine.
Here's the initial team of
four people from Snapchat
that now uses App
Engine to exchange
350 million photos per day.
Compute Engine, our
infrastructure as a service,
leverages the same reliable
highly-distributed data
storage layers
used by App Engine,
adding mountable persistent
disk storage to the mix.
These talk to the
Compute Engine VMs,
which are heavier weight than
the App Engine instances.
On top of these we have
a powerful load balancer,
which connects the
system to the internet.
The graph highlights
the stability
of the load-balancing service,
one million requests per second
without any pre-warming.
We can patch and maintain
hosts without any downtime
to the running VM.
When Right Scale
tested this, they
saw nothing, which means that
the feature works as expected.
And of course, we can
combine these solutions,
allowing for App
Engine instances
to run on Compute Engine's
VMs, opening the system up
to doing massive compute tasks
with a powerful scheduling
dynamic resource allocation
features of App Engine,
the continuum of computing.
So what brings us
to Google scale?
It's the pipes and
wires, bolts and fiber,
engineering excellence,
and raw computing power.
This data center
in Finland is green
because it is built
in an old mill.
Using the pre-existing
water infrastructure
to cool our server racks,
we've spent the last 15 years
engineering beautiful solutions.
Solutions we can
now share with you.
Come to cloud.google.com where
you can see case studies.
And go to
developers.google.com/cloud
to check out our APIs.
Come and leverage the
power of Google scale.